hello my name is William mcLaughlin I go
to something grammar school and I'm 15
years old and I have two questions for
you firstly do you believe that the
universe is infinite ongoing or does it
just simply stop at certain point and
secondly do you believe that God creates
the universe or higher power or you
simply an astrophysicist who believes in
science well William I yes I do think
the universe is infinite but of course I
can't prove it so far the universe has
allowed us to see 13.7 light billion
light years in every direction and we
can only guess what's beyond that so on
the other hand it's a pretty good guess
that we're not so special that we're at
the center so if the universe is not
infinite it's extremely extremely
extremely large that's a pretty good
guess now you're asking also does it
stop at a certain point probably not but
we don't know we certainly cannot
measure any place where it stops
we imagine that if we were standing at a
place thirteen billion light years say
directly north of us and we were on
another galaxy over there we would look
around and we would see a universe that
looks a lot like what earthbound
astronomers are seeing today so they
would probably be asking the same
question over there today and they would
probably come to the same conclusion
that their universe also looks extremely
large and almost infinite but they would
not be able to prove it so that's part
of the answer to your question you also
wanted to know what made this happen do
I think that a God made this or God made
this the short version of the answer is
yes I'm an astrophysicist and I measure
things and I am NOT able to answer the
question of what came before that or why
did it happen
you physicists cannot tell you what came
before the universe it's not a
meaningful question for us yet so maybe
it will be someday but so far we just
talked about process how material turns
into different forms of material and how
the changes happen through history I
think it's a wonderful story and very
exciting and really pleased to be a part
of discovery
story